i'll never forget i um there's this guy
and i
i talk about in the book there was this
was one of the first times i felt
if i felt real again almost and um
i'd help this guy and he didn't know who
i was
he didn't know me for what i'd done he
didn't know my name
i was just a guy in a uniform and there
when he needed help and he like thanked
me and was so appreciative
and i was like that feels good that
feels good he didn't have any
any assumption of who i was or how i was
you know what i mean like that guy just
needed that moment
and i could be there for him and it
shows me that i still got it
that i still got it you know because i
mean you get off and like how long do
you get out of the military
we've talked about this how long do you
get out of the military
and you can still you can still walk
around
with this i'm a warrior but you haven't
even had to get in the ring
how long does that credibility still
give you i'm a warrior
today not i was a warrior but i am a
warrior how long do you get that
credibility without getting in the ring
you know and it's always a struggle
that's always a struggle is
do i still have it could i still do it
could i still perform at that level
because at the day you can't
you have to say i was a warrior
you know and it's like
i mean you have to be tested and that's
the one thing you talk david godkins
like that guy
he tests himself all the time he's
always pushing it
but but that's like yeah i mean that's
the struggle is it's like
could i steal like and like the further
i get away from that day in afghanistan
you know like i question myself all the
time of
did i how could i have done that that
day but like
today i don't today i can't even
you know get myself to have enough
discipline to go work out
what happened to me do you know
so when you get
when you get done like how long did it
take for the
for the damn ceremonies and the round of
interview i remember i remember you and
i were talking on the phone
i forget when but you were talking about
like
you were on 16 minutes you were on all
the like every what freaking letterman
you did everything yeah how long did
that
did that last for you know like i was
i was like it was really crazy all the
way all the way up to i got it in
september 15th of 2011.
through december it was crazy i mean i
was on the view 60 minutes cbs sunday
morning
fox all the time i was on um
uh obviously letterman um jay leno
i mean you guys looked at everything
down down the list
and it was i mean it was crazy i mean it
was crazy
and um it's still like speeches kept
going like i mean you still walk out
places and people recognize you and you
know everybody's coming at you and
wanting you and this and that
and and it was it took me like i hated
it
i was i mean i when i hear people say
hey i met you back in two but anytime
i'm like when did you meet me
if it was between 2011 and 2014
i apologize first thing i said is i'm
sorry i'm sorry
i was drunk the whole time i hated it
like i hate it
like there would be times that like so i
had a whole team around me
the marine corps sent like right after
they announced i was getting the medal
the marine corps sent out like seven
people to live with me 24
7. what were they like
what were they doing i had like i had a
security guy
that stayed in my house like he stayed
with
i never i got i wasn't anywhere by
myself for
probably 90 days at least 120 days
and a guy live a guy lived with me um
they sent in like there were pr people
pao people like there was three of them
um
and you're 23 years old 23 years old how
was ty and steel
there's there's there's interviews you
go on the internet
and there's interviews um so they sent
divots out right so like the
dod the marine corps like combat camera
people like
capturing this there are images of like
i gotta refuse i'm like no
it's not changing my life and i'm
literally on a skid steer like working
under a skid steer and they're
interviewing me because
they had to get something and i would
not stop i'm like no you can follow me
but that's it so they would get up and
follow me to go work at
yards and stuff all day long but yeah i
mean so i had all that and
i mean it was just like a you know my
whole life changed
and and then you know it like everything
was good it's like they built me up
like i was i couldn't do anything wrong
and it's like when they got you the top
of the mountain it was like the pinata
they raise up
and then it was just like here came the
media just as soon as you said something
wrong or
i mean they were just it's the gotchas
and it was like it was like they just
build you up to just try to smash you
down right
there was always this one reporter who
was there um
they just always wanted to take me a
task so it's like you just got you had
to you just start
you take these beatings right and and
like it does like people are like oh who
cares
who cares what they say about you well
there's only one thing i've got in this
life
and that's my name and reputation that's
the only like when i die
on my tombstone it's not going to have
any of my awards
it's not going to have anything but the
day i was born and the day i died
and it's gonna say mire at the top of it
and that's what people are gonna know
that's my brand
and so i took it serious like when i
would come home and
i remember i landed one night and uh
i landed real late in louisville and i
was driving home
and the courier journal had
released on the front page across the
state because i remember i pulled into
this
gas station in my hometown and it was
across the state and it was medal of
dishonor
with my page on the front page of the
state paper right
and they were trying to discredit
everything that i'd done and
it was so bad that like my friends got
up like they found out about it
and they got up and they went and bought
all the papers out
in town and it was just always something
man
and it's just like you you just can't
there's no rhyme or reason to it you
know and and it's just a
yeah i mean it you get isolated so i get
i get what that guy said you know what
that guy did
um because i mean sometimes you just
you know what if i can't help people and
make a difference what am i doing
what are you doing so you say the like
the hype train
lasted from september to december
and i mean at some point does all of a
sudden those seven marines that were
there watching every move all sudden
like their
their duties over we got mired done with
whatever he need to get done
yeah and then like one day you wake up
and like gear it alone
yeah so we were supposed to go to so we
did uh east coast
west coast and we're supposed to hawaii
tour so it's like
we were like a weekend in new york and
then a week
in california and then we were supposed
to go to hawaii for like a week to do
press and all this right see the bases
and um
do the press on each coast and we went
to new york
did that so like i got the medal came
home
and then the week after that i was this
is when all this started
and uh by the time i hit california i'm
like i'm out
like i on the plane to california from
new york to california i said i can't
i'm i'm out i can't keep doing this
um and so that was it like what was it
that made you feel you could you're like
did the people just constantly talking
to you i mean was it just you feel like
you're put up on a pedestal and we
talked about this the first time you're
on here
i mean basically everyone's saying hey
good job i mean you gotta take this like
i am literally known
for the biggest failure of my life
like you you can't change the narrative
to
like that's where people get wrong is
they're like well like they justify
stuff in their head
the facts are this like you can't change
the facts
all my team is dead like i didn't get
them out
whether whether it was rational or not
somebody can say i'm going to do ten
thousand push-ups today
and they're trying to break a guinness
book of world record nobody looks at him
and says well
you you did you did 500 an hour that's
that's good enough
they failed i failed
my teammates are dead their families has
unanswered questions
there's you know there's there's four
kids
that'll never see their dad and i'm
getting parade around the nation
as a hero and
it's like i look at all these other
metal like all the other medal of honor
guys and
and i i'm away from them because you
know
i get look kyle carpenter i couldn't
imagine what that kid gone through like
you talk about a guy that's a
warrior that kid's a warrior i don't
have anything like that
and but i tell these i tell these guys
that like
you guys you guys did some badass stuff
you guys did bad ass stuff
and you got some guys to enjoy it with
i come home i ain't got anybody
and it's literally the biggest failure
of my life now with that i've learned a
lot
but i can't change the narrative because
it doesn't feel good
and you started you started feeling this
way while you're flying from new york to
california
like i mean i i told the president that
i couldn't accept the medal i wanted him
to break
it down to a navy cross i told him i
couldn't accept a medal because
like he said you're a hero i'll never
forget president obama told me that i
was a hero
and i said if you think i'm such a hero
why don't you call my teammates up
and get their opinion go let them know
i'm a hero
and i'm not and that's why like
that's why when these people are like
trying to discredit or they're trying to
say oh you know
whatever i mean i can't argue with them
you talk about getting my ass kicked
like i got a medal of honor for getting
my ass kicked
and so i just i couldn't keep living
this
in the media of like it just it was it
was a hard thing like
i just wasn't there yet right now i
don't do it about me i do about my
teammates
right like i do it to try to show these
lessons if hey
you know i come to this point to where i
wasn't going to change it i wasn't going
to be able to get away from it you know
it was like
and so how do i use it to make a
difference how do i try to turn
something
so terrible into something good and
that's what i ended up having to do but
yeah
i got off like on the plane to it was on
the plane to la
it was on the plane from new york to la
and i remember looking at the girl who
was running all my stuff
she was she's a rock star you talk about
a girl who she is a rock star and
um i said i we
we're done we're done we'll finish these
interviews here but we're not going to
hawaii
and i'm going home and landed
we did the stuff we had doing in la i
flew home from there
and then um i mean i was still doing
events and still doing what people
wanted me to i was i had a scholarship
fund with the marine corps scholarship
foundation
i had this challenge to america where we
would raise a million dollars to put
kids to
college so like i was going out speaking
at events for that to
like going to private dinners to where
somebody would write a huge check to
to the scholarship foundation so i was
doing that and then
yeah no i didn't have any nobody taught
me
what i should do what i shouldn't do you
know they it was like uh
23 years old just thrown to this
machine that i mean i didn't even have
an instagram at the time
right like i didn't i didn't know what
to do and um
so yeah i mean i did that i was on the
speaking like i did speaking with
leading authorities
um broke my book with being west in
2012.
and you know like speeches kept going
and like events and things like that
and um but just kind of just kind of
going with the flow of
what's next right and yeah
i did see what was the marine corps when
you said hey look i'm not going to
hawaii where i'm done
i'm done was the marine corps thinking
or did anybody say
okay hey maybe we need to give
dakota some like help to get through
this
because he's got a massive amount of
guilt over what happened
did anybody talk to you along those
lines at all so the marine corps didn't
know what to do either
right like i was the first living marine
since vietnam
to receive the medal of honor so they
weren't really schooled up on it either
and um there was one mistake that they
made
uh in from the beginning is
um and they tried to put it together but
when they put the narrative together
this is what opened us up to the media
to the the um
the guy who actually was the reporter
that was actually the one that
just was trying to discredit everything
and this was his heart this hit
this is a piece he honed on but like in
the in the first
initial write-up they had to do right
they put numbers in of how many people
were rescued
or say whatever you want to call it and
how many people i killed
which opened it up
to numbers which a doesn't matter
and b opens it up right because it
doesn't really matter did you did you
kill
28 people or 72 people or 172 people
it's like it's all it doesn't really
matter
right did you save because you can get a
medal of honor for saving one person
you can get a medal of honor for for
killing one person yeah
you can get a medal of honor for saving
100 or killing 100 it's that's not what
it's about
but if they open it up for that all of a
sudden they make it matter
and that's and that was where it messed
up and i think like there started
that the negative stuff started coming
out and
that was where but like the reporter
even says in his article there's an
article out there about like well
there's quite a few
but he even states he goes um he was
um he states all these things these
discrepancies
but he goes i'm not saying he doesn't
deserve it
i actually read that article yesterday
yeah he said he says
something along the lines of not that
these actions alone don't
fully warrant the medal of honor yeah so
what the hell are you doing
yeah so it's those things that like
you know a guy like me and like you you
have you've had to talk me down
a guy like me all i've known my whole
life
like i'm not there's only one thing i'm
good at and it's fighting
it's all i know like i have been
it's all i know you know what i mean
like it's the only thing that's made me
successful at anything is that i was
willing to fight
and i was willing to work and
you put those things
in a spot where there's there's people
who are poking
it's not a good it's not a good thing
right
and and so like i had to back up
you know get myself together i was
drinking too much like i was just trying
to deal with all of it i mean i mean
imagine walking into a room and
everybody wants to talk to you about
the worst day of your life
like over and over and
over and it's like you don't have to
it's not about going home and not
dreaming about it it's about
i'm walking into rooms and i'm sitting
here literally
reliving it over and over and over
which which is is okay
um but i just i just think that like
sometimes the worst day of my life is
somebody else's entertainment
i i wish i would have pulled this quote
um
major whittlesey he was at like a dinner
and spoke at the dinner he sits down
with his friends and they
their friends were talking they said
something along the lines of he said
exactly what you just said exactly what
you just said he said something along
the lines of
every time i talk about this i go right
back there
and i can't get away from it yeah
yeah like yeah yeah i mean i just
i mean look i still today i miss
my guys i mean you know i
i just seen that one of my like uh one
of my teammates
his his daughter's a you know she's
about to have a baby
and you know you just it's just it's
crazy
you know what i mean it's like i get to
sit here and enjoy my two beautiful
daughters who are
more than i ever deserve i get to i get
to hang around such amazing people and i
get to live
a beautiful life and and all these
things
and you know it's just it's not
it's not a fair world you know
it's not and that's that was always the
thing you know struggle for me to deal
with and
you know how do you give back how do you
continue to give back right like what
look i mean i yeah
how do you get back right so yeah so
like the marine corps left they went on
their own way
honestly they kind of separated from me
i didn't hear much from them again
uh probably two and a half two two and a
half years
and hear much from them it was like
mission complete for them
it was like hey let's separate from this
because i don't know if this thing's
gonna be a hand grenade or
you know what's gonna happen